[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis willkommen an diesem
Samstagabend den Sport hat für Sie
Norbert König guten Abend und wir
blicken ausführlich auf den Nahen Osten
Hilfslieferungen für Gaza erste Lkw
passieren den Grenzübergang Raffa und
eine Friedenskonferenz in Ciro ringt um
eine diplomatische Lösung des
Konflikts Sturmflut an der Ostsee die
Wassermassen erreichen historische
Höchstwerte und richten Schäden in
Millionen Höhe an und riesenandrank in
Frankfurt Promis Autoren und Literatur
beim Publikumstag auf der
buchmeisee nach langen Verhandlungen ist
jetzt also der Grenzübergang zwischen
Ägypten und Gaza für Hilfslieferungen
geöffnet wir blicken gleich darauf
zuerst aber schauen wir nach nach
Ägypten denn da findet heute eine
naahostkonferenz statt ein Gipfel für
den Frieden wie er offiziell heißt am
Verhandlungstisch sitzen unter anderem
die Vereinten Nationen und die EU
außerdem sind wichtige Staaten aus der
Region dabei neben Ägypten etwa
Jordanien Saudi-Arabien oder Katar viele
der insgesamt rund 30 Länder schickten
ihre Außenministerin und Minister zu den
Gipfel darunter auch Deutschland und es
gibt einen Haken keine der direkten
Konfliktparteien ist dabei
a Kairo berichtet Anna
Feist es sollte der ganz große Wurf
werden Ägypten hat zum Friedensgipfel
geladen die Konferenz ausgetragen in
Kairos neuer administrativen Hauptstadt
übertragen mit eigenem Livestream und
Countdown der sogleich die seit Tagen
erwartete Grenzöffnung begleitet
erstmals dürfen 20 LKW voller Wasser
Essen und Medizin passieren unter dem
Logo des friedengipfels auf der Agenda
die Konkretisierung der humanitären
Hilfen für
eine Feuerpause und die Aufnahme für die
Verhandlungen einer
Zweistaatenlösung der ägyptische
Staatschef gibt sich als
hoffnungsbringer das Ziel der
Konferenz dass es morgen besser sein
wird als heute wie die Vision der
Ägypter für einen Frieden aussieht zeigt
dann eine Art Werbespot politpropaganda
in der Mittagspause eine israelische
Festival Besucherin hat sich nach dem
Angriff der Hamas in der Wüste verirrt
sie trifft auf einen verletzten
palästinensischen Jungen der seine
Familie bei den Angriffen auf Gaza
verloren hat der kleine Junge fordert
die Israelin auf du weißt wer hinter den
Bombardierungen steckt oder warum um
ihnen zu sagen dass sie mit dem Krieg
aufhören sollen eine für westliche Ohren
zynische Botschaft an Israel an das Land
das gar nicht erst eingeladen wurde ein
Friedensgipfel also ohne die
Konfliktparteien den neben Israel fehlt
auch der Iran der Verbündete der
Terrororganisation Hamas und selbst
Israels schutzm die USA haben lediglich
eine Diplomatin geschickt mitten in der
Konferenz verschwindet dann auch noch
der so wichtige Vermittler zwischen der
Terrororganisation Hamas und dem Rest
der Welt der Emir von Qatar ohne sein
Statement zu geben es könnte also besser
laufen für den Frieden auf dem
Friedensgipfel sprechen wir über den
Gipfel mit Michael bewerunge für uns in
Israel und mit gline atai in Ägypten
zuerst zu ihnen goline was wird dieser
Gipfel wohl
bringen
nun zwei sehr unterschiedliche
Sichtweisen sind heute hier in Kairo
zusammengekommen für die europäische
Seite die immer wieder betont hat das
Recht auf Selbstverteidigung Israels die
immer wieder klar die Rolle der Hamas
verurteilt hat und dann die arabischen
Länder die immer wieder auf eine
Feuerpause auf eine unmittelbare
Feuerpause gedrängt haben und die die
Rolle der Hamas nicht wirklich
konkretisiert haben es hat es ist zu
keiner Einigung gekommen beide Seiten
konnten sich er konnten nicht
zusammenkommen es hat von der arabischen
Seite auch sehr viel Kritik an den
westlichen Staaten gegeben für die
deutsche Außenministerin die gerade hier
ihre Pressekonferenz gegeben hat ist das
keine Überraschung gewesen dass man so
auseinandergegangen ist trotzdem hat sie
soeben gesagt blickt sie positiv auf
diese Konferenz denn sie sei auch ein
Ausdruck dessen dass man sich nicht
auseinandertreiben ließe genau das sei
das Ziel der Hamas und
man arbeitet doch in sehr viel Fragen
gemeinsam als Partner insofern sei diese
Konferenz in Ciro auch eine klare
Botschaft an die Hamas dass man eine
Spaltung nicht erleben werde gehen wir
nach Israel zu ihnen Michael wie wird
bei Ihnen diese naostkonferenz
gesehen in Israel gab es heute keine
offizielle Reaktion auf diese Konferenz
und ich glaube das lag nicht nur daran
dass heute Schabbat ist in Israel im
politischen Israel wird diese Konferenz
als wenig hilfreich angesehen weil dort
schlicht die Interessen Israels nicht
vertreten werden die gehen dahin die
Hamas zu zerschlagen zumindest die
militärische Macht der Hamas zu
zerschlagen und zu verhindern dass so
etwas wie der 7 Oktober wieder passiert
das geht aus israelischer Sicht nur über
eine Bodenoffensive und die wurde auch
heute weiter vorbereitet allerdings gibt
es Druck offenbar von den USA und
anderen westlichen Staaten diese
Bodenoffensive zumindest heraus zu
schieben und auch in Israel gibt's eine
starke Lobby der Angehörigen die mehr
Raum für Verhandlungen für die
Freilassung der Geiseln fordert denn mit
einer Bodenoffensive wären diese
Verhandlungen wohl erstmal beendet danke
für diese Einschätzung Micha bewunger
und goline
ATI und unter den Verschleppten Geiseln
sind auch israelische Soldaten über
deren Freilassung will die terroriliz
Hamas nach Angaben einer ihrer Sprecher
erst nach dem Krieg verhandeln was die
entführt Zivilistinnen und Zivilisten
angeht hat sich jetzt Vermittler Katar
geäußert wir sind auf einem Weg der sehr
bald zur Freilassung der Geiseln
insbesondere der Zivilisten führen wird
erklärte der Sprecher des katarischen
Außenministeriums al Ansari laut
Medienberichten l
berichtet frei nach 14 Tagen in den
Händen der hamasterroristen Judit ranan
und ihre Tochter Natalie konnten gestern
Abend von rotkreuzmitarbeitern in
Empfang genommen werden Erle bei der
Familie Hoffnungsschimmer für das
Schicksal der 200 zurückgebliebenen
Geiseln wir waren total überrascht ein
überwältigendes Gefühl und eine Mischung
aus Freude aber auch Betroffenheit und
Schuld weil noch so viele andere auf
Rettung
warten militärisch bleibt die Lage
angespannt an der Grenze zum Libanon
wurde heute ein israelischer Soldat bei
Artilleriebeschuss der Hisbollah getötet
die Bewohner zahlreiche Ortschaften sind
inzwischen evakuiert ähnlich das Bild
jenseits der Grenze im südlibanesischen
Tyros werden Bewohner von der Grenze in
Schulen
umquartiert ich hoffe natürlich dass die
Dinge sich wieder beruhigen aber die
Nachrichten sind derzeit eher schlecht
Israels Armee befürchtet auch im Norden
meerkämpfe man sei auf Angriffe der
Hisbollah vorbereitet sagt der
verteidigungsministerboll hat
entschieden in diesen Kampf einzutreten
wir haben keine Wahl wir haben diesen
Krieg nicht gewollt sie zwingen ihn uns
auf weiter südlich im Gazastreifen
warteten auch heute wieder Palästinenser
mit ausländischem Pass auf eine Ausreise
nach Ägypten für Hilfsgüter wurde die
Grenze geöffnet für diese Menschen
bislang noch
nicht und auch heute haben wegen des
Krieges im Nahen Osten wieder in
mehreren deutschen Städten Menschen
demonstriert der Vorsitzende des
Zentralrats der muslimeiman masiek sagt
im AD Fernsehen er mache sich große
Sorgen über die Lage in Deutschland auf
den Straßen sein derzeit Hass Gewalt und
Antisemitismus zu sehen einige
propalästinensische Proteste sind
zuletzt wegen befürchteter Straftaten
verboten worden einige wurden erlaubt
wie in Düsseldorf Heiko Rams berichtet
wirind
ein Zug zieht sich am Nachmittag einmal
quer durch die Düsseldorfer Innenstadt
darunter viele Familien mit Kindern es
sind deutlich mehr Menschen als erwartet
viele haben Angst um ihre Familie im
Gazastreifen warum demonstrieren Sie
heute hier weil das was in unserer
Heimat in Gaza passiert absolut
unmenschlich ist das kann man nicht
dulden das können wir nicht akzeptieren
und deshalb demonstrieren wir auf
friedlicher artise bitte den Schutz
geben für diesen Leute die in
gaserstreifen Leben für die Ärzte
die Kinder für die kleine Kinder für
Frauen für alle Zivilisten die da sind
das ist krass D einfach so
viele Deutsche auch hier sind und
mitunterstützen und das ist so wichtig
dass man einfach gemeinsam hier steht in
Düsseldorf blieb alles weitgehend
friedlich so die Polizei es kam zu
keinen Ausschreitungen wir haben in der
Spitze bis zu 6900 teilnehmende gezählt
und untermStrich haben wir mehrere
Strafanzeigen dennoch fertig müssen
angemeldet waren heute bundesweit
zahlreiche proalästinensische
Demonstrationen darunter in München und
Frankfurt verboten wurde eine Kundgebung
in Hamburg es kamen aber trotzdem etwa
300 Menschen die Polizei löste die
Kundgebung auf etwa 100 Demonstranten
wurden in Gewahrsam
genommen
dernerostkonflikt war auch ein Thema
heute beim Treffen der
Nachwuchsorganisation von CDU und CSU in
Braunschweig beim Deutschlandtag der
Junge
zunächst großer Applaus für die Rede des
israelischen
Botschafters in der Innenpolitik
erwartet cduchef märz von der Regierung
schnell wirksame Maßnahmen gegen
illegale Migration spätestens 2025 wolle
man die ampelregierung Ablösen der CSU
Vorsitzende Söder forderte die aktuelle
Regierung auf am besten gleich
abzutreten es sei die schlechteste
Bundesregierung die man je
hatte es deutet sich ja an dass die
Linken SAR Wagenknecht bald eine eigene
Partei gründen wird SPD Parteichef Lars
Klingbeil hat daher jetzt betont dass
die Türen der SPD offen stehen würden
für Mitglieder der Linken ich werde
jetzt keine mitgliedsformularare in der
Linkspartei verteilen aber natürlich
gilt wer sich für Freiheit Gerechtigkeit
und Solidarität einsetzt und in unserem
Land etwas bewegen will ist in der SPD
willkommen sagte Klingbeil der Welt am
Sonntag die Nacht war turbulent für die
Menschen an der Ostsee das Ausmaß der
Sturmflut historisch in flenszburg
überschritt das Hochwasser mit 2,27 m
über normal den bisherigen Höchstwert
von vor 120 Jahren die Pegelstände
sinken wieder jetzt laufen die
Aufräumarbeiten der katastrophenschlutz
in Schleswig-Holstein geht von Schäden
in dreistelliger Millionenhöhe aus
Henner Hebestreit mit einer Bilanz an
Schleswig-Holsteins Ostseeküste konnten
gleich mehrere Deiche dem Druck des
Hochwassers nicht mehr stand ten 2000
Menschen wurden in der Nacht
aufgefordert sich in Sicherheit zu
bringen in Notunterkünften wie hier in
brodersbi verbrachten viele bange
Stunden es war schon sehr gespenstisch
und unheimlich einmal der starke Sturm
dann auch das Wasser auf femann wehte
der Sturm einen Baum auf ein Auto dabei
starb die 33-Jährige Fahrerin das
Unwetter ist mit solcher Wucht über die
Ostseeküste gezogen dass in vielen Häfen
schwere Segeljachten wie Spielzeug
durcheinander geschleudert wordurden es
war ergreifend sowas habe ich auch in
meiner ganzen Zeit hier noch nicht
erlebt die Wellen sind also wirklich
apokalyptisch hier in den Hafen
reingeschlagen muss mir sehr viel Sorgen
machen ob wir das alles wieder so
hergerichtet kriegen damit wir im
nächsten Jahr auch wieder eine kila
Woche veranstalen können landesweit
wurden die Retter zu Tausenden Einsätzen
gerufen die Schäden liegen nach ersten
Schätzungen im dreistelligen
Millionenbereich das Land zieht auch den
Bund in der Pflicht klar ist aber dass
wir natürlich helfen werden dass wir
jetzt eine Bestandsaufnahme machen was
sind für Schäden entstanden es ist
wichtig dass Küstenschutz eine
Gemeinschaftsaufgabe von Bund und Land
auch ist auch in Mecklenburg Vorpommern
hat der Sturm schwere Schäden
angerichtet auf dem das durchbrach das
Hochwasser ebenfalls mehrere Deiche es
ist außergewöhnlich hoch wir haben das
an dieser Lage sehr sehr oft aber es ist
so hoch war es ganz ganz lange nicht
auch hier sind die Helfer unermüdlich im
Einsatz um die Schäden dieser
rekordsturmflut zu
beseitigen Bücher nicht nur lesen
sondern über Bücher sprechen mit anderen
oder am besten mit den Autorinnen und
Autoren das ist für viele das größte auf
der Frankfurter Buchmesse gerade sind ja
dort die Publikumstage und die Hallen
wie Sie sehen können wieder sehr gut
gefüllt Inken Klinge war für uns
dort für eine Widmung vom Krimi Autor
Sebastian Fitzek reicht die Schlange
weit bis nach draußen heute schon
ser voll durch die Menge sich
durchzuquetschen auch an diesem
verlagstand drängen sich Menschen Massen
wegen einer Schriftstellerin die in den
sozialen Medien empfohlen wird über den
hashbookt außerdem sind ihre bunten
buchränder die farbschnitte der Renner
auf der Messe das ist ein wahnsinniger
Hal also bei allen Verlagen das ist ganz
häufig dass Farbschnitt in der
Erstauflage angeboten wird einer der
seit Jahrzehnten die Menge begeistert
ist
es er hat ein kunstgeschichtliches Buch
verfasst natürlich inklusive
Ottifanten der Elefant ist ja der tifant
ist ja so vernachlässigt worden in der
ablischen Malerei und plötzlich taucht
auch in den klassischen Werken auf das
interessiert auch die Jugend und
plötzlich sind sie alle wieder da der
weiterhin etwas schwächelnden
Buchbranche tun die rappelvollen
messerhallen sicherlich gut gefragt sind
besonders auch Kinder und Jugendbücher
Cornelia Funke hat ihre tintenweltreihe
nach vielen Jahren fortgesetzt der Titel
die Farbe der Rache sage viel meint sie
der sagt dass es um um ein Gefühl geht
an dem die Welt gerade auch wieder sehr
leidet nicht dass wir immer wieder Rache
für irgendetwas nehmen müssen tun das W
dass wir einander nicht verstehen morgen
kann noch den ganzen Tag geguckt gelesen
gekauft werden und im ein oder anderen
Prominenten Gesicht begegnet man
vermutlich auch auf der Frankfurter
Buchmesse und jetzt kommen wir zum Sport
fast ein Viertel der bundesligaaison der
Männer ist schon vorbei und die Fans von
Union Berlin erleben harte Zeiten ja und
die denken wehmütig denke ich mal an
vergangene Zeiten die vergangene
Spielzeit nämlich denn da hatten die
Unioner historisches geleistet und sich
erstmals für die Champions League
qualifiziert nach dem 0:3 heute gegen
den VfB Stuttgart ist Krise angesagt es
ist die achte Pflichtspielniederlage
nacheinander Stuttgarts girassie trifft
an Alter an der Alten Försterei zum 14
Mal im achten Spiel Leverkusen auf
Erfolgskurs 2:1 in Wolfsburg Darmstadt g
Leipzig 1:3 Hoffenheim gegen Frankfurt
auch 1:3 den einzigen Heimsieg am
Nachmittag feiert Freiburg 2:1 gegen
Bochum ausführlich im Sportstudio das
Abendspiel Mainz gegen München gestern
Dortmund gegen Bremen 1:0 morgen zwei
Spiele Leverkusen bleibt ungeschlagen
und Tabellenführer vor dem
Überraschungsteam aus Stuttgart die
Bayern können Dortmund wieder auf Platz
4 verdrängen Leipzig überholt Hoffenheim
Wolfsburg fällt zurück auf ne fünf
Punkte dahinter die zweite
Tabellenhälfte Union weiter nahe an der
Abstiegszone in der Augsburg Mainz und
Köln noch punkten können das aktuelle
sportstudio mit der Fußball Bundesliga
und der Betrachtung um 23 Uhr wie der
Nahostkonflikt den Profisport
beeinflusst die Fußballwelt trauert um
eine englische Legende Sir Bobby
Charlton Weltmeister von
1966 und hochverehrter Profi bei
Manchester United ist im Alter von 86
Jen
gestorben er war eine der fußballikonen
Englands geboren 1937 in ashington ganz
im Nordosten Robert genannt Bobby chton
mit seinen Treffern im WM Halbfinale
1966 gegen Portugal schießt er England
ins Endspiel und gewinnt mit den Three
Lions das legendäre Finale von Wembley
gegen Deutschland und wird im eigenen
Land Weltmeister 1994 schlägt in die
Queen zum
Ritter seine bitterste Stunde 198 50
beim Flugzeugunglück von München sterben
acht seiner Teamkollegen von Manchester
United chton überlebt und feiert 10
Jahre später triumphal mit Manchester
den Sieg im Europapokal der
Landesmeister 20 Jahre dauert seine
Karriere 249 Tore in 748 spielen Sir
Bobby chton wird als einer der großen
des Fußballs in Erinnerung
bleiben sie wollten Anschluss finden an
die Spitze der Frauenbundesliga das ein
Z ein zwischen der SGS Essen und Werder
Bremen hilft aber keinem Team richtig
weiter die Bremerinnen in Weiß Tabellen
fünfte nach zwei Siegen aus vier Spielen
zeigen in Essen kein gutes Spiel gehen
aber in Führung Flanke karaahn und Lina
hausike zum 1-0 in der 55 Minute
Essen spielt besser kommt aber erst nach
einem Bremer Abwehrfehler kurz vor
Schluss zum Erfolg Ramona Meer zum ein
zu ein Endstand Essen und Bremen bleiben
Punkt gleich Tabellennachbarn vor der
Länderspielpause in der Frauen
buundesliga die All Blacks das Rugby
Nationalteam Neuseelands sind mit einem
klaren Sieg gegen Argentinien ins
Weltmeisterschaftsfinale eingezogen am
Ende hieß es in Paris 44 Z6 für
Neuseeland die Auftaktniederlage gegen
Frankreich ist vergessen der fünfte
Titel soll her egal ob der Gegner
England oder Südafrika heißen wird sie
sind
bereit immer wieder immer wieder beeindr
so Übergabe machst jetzt nicht zu
mir bin schon bisschen heiser da wird's
passen das Wetter ist morgen im Osten
und Süden meist freundlich sonst stark
bewölkt und zeitweise etwas Regen die
Einzelheiten gleich von Christer Orben
das heute journal läuft an diesem Abend
um 22:45 Uhr mit Anne gellineck
[Musik]
tschüss
guten Abend das Sturmtief wolfgang hat
jetzt auch in Ostengland und in
Schottland für schwere Schäden gesorgt
uns beeinflusst es aber nur noch mit
etwas Regen und auch dieses Tief das
über Polen hinwegzieht streift uns nur
viel Regen gibt es allerdings mit einem
weiteren tief über Südwesteuropa in den
nächsten Tagen und wir gelangen dadurch
wieder in den Zustrom feucht warmer Luft
nachts kann es aber trotzdem Auskühlen
morgen früh meist 6 bis 9° im Westen 10
bis 12 ° da kommen nämlich neue Wolken
mit etwas Regen auf da frischt auch der
Wind wieder auf sonst lässt der Wind
nach kräftigeren Regen gibt's auch mal
zwischen den Alpen und der Lausitz
dazwischen lockert es aber auf morgen
Vormittag gibt's ein Wechsel aus Sonne
und Wolken und trockenes Wetter zwischen
der Ostsee und dem Schwarzwald der Regen
im Südosten der lässt rasch nach auch
aus den Wolken zwischen der Nordsee und
dem saarand fällt nicht allzu viel
heraus das kann sich am Nachmittag dann
auch mal in Richtung Mitte ausweiten und
trotz stömischer böhnen an der Nordsee
und in den hoch Lagen des Westens ist
das morgen insgesamt ein ruhiger Tag bei
11° in der Eifel und 18° am oberrein am
Montag gibt es mal Sonne mal Nebel ab
Dienstag wird es dann deutlich grauer
und wieder nasser und damit auf
Wiedersehen